mesdames messieurs bonjour la tension
monte dans leur bus détourné en effet
les terroristes chantent et font chanter
les otages ne respectant pas cela les
conventions de genève qui précise que
les otages doivent mourir dans le calme
mais rassurons nous les forces de
l'ordre sont déjà sur place 35000 crs 45
mille gendarmes mobiles trois
bombardiers lourds et cinq camions de
retard pour le ravitaillement j'espère
pouvoir vous communiquer rapidement les
revendications des pirates de l'air que
nous ne connaissons toujours pas et j'en
profite pour vous communiquer les
résultats du loto cette semaine il
fallait jouer le 16
le 61 attendant la tonalité puis le 21
09 55
à tout à l'heure merci revendiquer tu
veux des revendications attendre sache
que ça veut dire hey tu vas voir
indiquer aux essarts je trouve moi vendu
qu elles soient qui revendiquent et
revendiquez vous revendre 20 revendiquer
produit alors revendiquer âme de morts
qu'on croyait disparue et qui met pas en
revenant revendique et à sauter une
ligne enfin revendiquer la arazi avec
j'ai souhaité une ligne alors
revendiquer du latin vingt dix cars et
vt du premier groupe
ouais actions de réclamer qqch qui vous
appartient et donc ton et privés qqc
hanche alors que mais le dhs et de
comprendre me cherche pas à qqch enfin
qu'est-ce que ces qq ch qqch qu'est ce
que c'est que ces acheter quelque chose
quelque chose qu'est ce que c'est c'est
quelqu'un est ce quelqu'un en
l'occurence et quelques unes et 7
quelques unes en l'occurrence et la
belle et pulpeuse ginette krombach celle
que je veux et quand saura que tu chc
ginai grand mare ouais
[Musique]